costa rica irá al balotaje en luego de
que ninguno de los 25 candidatos a la
presidencia del país alcanzará el 40 por
ciento de los votos necesarios para ser
declarado ganador en esta primera vuelta
de ayer domingo el próximo 3 de abril
entonces se enfrentarán en las urnas del
ex presidente josé maría figueres olsen
y el economista rodrigo chávez el
abstencionismo fue otro protagonista de
esta jornada más del 40 por ciento de
los votantes no asistió a las urnas a lo
que sería el número más alto de la
historia de ese país para ello entonces
quiero saludar a nuestra segunda
invitada ella es maría fernanda
bustamante politóloga y analista gracias
maría fernanda por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
muy buen día le pregunta entonces el
balance de esta primera vuelta de
elecciones en costa rica
buenos días will vamos a estar acá sí
claro ante las abstenciones lo que
tenemos en el país es realmente
preocupante
cómo se va a elegir al presidente
finalmente la segunda ronda y además de
esto
preocupa muchísimo los retos a nivel
país con tanta participación
ausente es decir la pandemia ha hecho
que la gestión política sea más
complicada y si sumamos que la tendencia
política de costa rica no es estable es
decir después de que vencimos el
bipartidismo en el año 2000 todavía no
hay un grupo o un bloque político que
ofrezca un proyecto y cuya
representación sea amplia tenemos una
tarea muy complicada para abrir maria
fernanda por qué tanta abstención porque
tan alta digamos que qué porcentaje de
la población o mejor dicho qué parte de
la población es la que más se abstiene
digamos en este caso pueden ser los
jóvenes por qué es este fenómeno
claro como le contaba el abstencionismo
en este país
empiezan por ahí del 1948 y se mantiene
hasta 2002 la política tradicional en
este sentido los votantes con mayor edad
los adultos tienen una fuerte tendencia
a asistir al voto sin embargo aquel voto
joven que no tienen este arraigo
cultural no tiene ese arraigo histórico
y ha sido muy complicado para los
partidos
posicionarse o ser atractivos para el
voto joven y además de esto en esta
campaña tuvimos 25 opciones políticas
para gobernar de estas rodrigo chávez
fue quien un salió beneficiado con un
discurso económico con un discurso de
atender a la principal necesidad del
país en este momento porque ya teníamos
un déficit fiscal alto sin embargo
también ahora va a ser muy interesante
ver cómo se reacciona
con una segunda vuelta con rodrigo
chávez porque es su primera vez y
también es la primera vez donde el
electorado va a tener que decidir si una
figura tradicional o una figura entre
comillas novedosa es lo que
prefiere
digamos entonces que podría pasar el
próximo 3 de abril se puede mantener
entonces las cosas como esta nos digamos
josé maría figueres que ganó en esta
primera vuelta sería un posible ganador
o pudiera ocurrir lo que estábamos
hablando que rodrigo chaves remonte y
pues digamos gane en la presidencia en
esta oportunidad que dicen las encuestas
cómo se puede comportar costa rica en
este próximo 3 de abril de 3 de abril
perdón
bueno de momento con el resultado lo
preliminar lo obtenemos ayer cerca de
las 11 de la noche fue el último corte
el resultado definitivo comienza a
partir de mañana a mediodía sin embargo
es
podemos decir que el candidato josé
maría figueres tiene los 70 años del
partido en existencia y en ejercicio a
favor en cambio rodrigo chávez tiene o
esta primera experiencia y en esta
primera campaña ha sido altamente
criticado por las denuncias comprobadas
de acoso en la institución del banco
mundial a nivel país por supuesto que
esto ha sido una crítica importante para
los sectores jóvenes para los sectores
feministas
entonces quizás de momento de forma
preliminar puede que rodrigo chávez
repunte con su con su afiliación o su
simpatía sin embargo como le repito el
candidato josé maría figueres tiene una
alta data y tiene una base electoral muy
amplia en el país por lo que dependerá
totalmente de sus participaciones
públicas en estos dos meses vamos a ver
entonces qué va a pasar el próximo 13 de
abril todo puede pasar pues hay que
esperar ese día para ver quién va a ser
entonces el próximo presidente de costa
rica y le pregunta entonces
cuáles son los retos que tiene que
afrontar este próximo mandatario como
deja el país el presidente ha librado
es una situación bastante compleja de
hecho en el electorado el partido
oficialista no llega al congreso no
logra ni siquiera un scan lo que refleja
digamos la apatía que siente el
electorado por su administración que
duró dos años en el poder y también ante
la pandemia el déficit fiscal que
teníamos en el 2017 el índice de
desempleo
las faltantes estructurales en tm en
términos de desarrollo humano son
principalmente los retos que deben
encaminarse para la nueva administración
independientemente de cuál sea el
candidato que llegue por la presidencia
por otro lado preocupa de sobremanera
cuáles van a ser las acciones de largo
plazo
una vez que queremos ya atravesado los
dos años de pandemia en el país verdad a
nivel mundial entonces vamos a tener una
asamblea ya se conoce una asamblea
altamente multipartidista lo cual va a
dificultar los acuerdos y en este
sentido vamos a experimentar las
problemáticas que tenga el poder
ejecutivo para negociar estas acciones a
largo plazo maria fernanda usted hablaba
de la asamblea y quiero ahondar en este
punto entonces como quedan ahí las
fuerzas políticas representadas qué
lectura le podemos hacer también a las
elecciones de legislativo
correcto bueno las elecciones de
legislativo como decía son altamente
multipartidistas ningún partido político
logra avanzar proyectos por sí solo
todos son dependientes en este caso la
bancada del precio del candidato a la
presidencia josé maría villalta es la
mayor que ronda entre los 17 diputados
porque en costa rica el congreso está
compuesto por 57 son relativamente pocas
personas le sigue en este momento su
rival rodrigo charles y posterior a esto
tenemos a un partido tradicional que
hace por lo menos cuatro
administraciones no tenía mayoría ni
cerca en el congreso que es el partido
unidad social cristiana
el repito un dato interesante es que el
partido oficialista que hoy todavía está
en ejercicio no llegó a concluir ni
siquiera un escaño en la asamblea maría
fernando ya por último que quiero
preguntar cómo están las calles de costa
rica que dice la gente están realmente
ya pues cansadas de la política o sea
que que cuál es la lectura que le hace a
la sociedad costarricense en este
momento para también así saber cómo
puede reaccionar el próximo 3 de abril
claro
en términos generales en costa rica las
personas que votan lo hacen de una
manera pacífica con felicidad todas las
encuestas apuntan a que el costarricense
siente este deber cívico de votar el día
de ayer en las calles estaban bastante
concurridas no había restricción
vehicular- entonces también se pudo
observar en todos los cantones distritos
y provincias de este país algún nivel de
movilización sin embargo tras el
resultado como es muy tarde en la noche
y gloria ya hoy podemos observar las
primeras reacciones de quienes van a
segunda ronda cuáles son los argumentos
también podemos observar que hay las
críticas son las contradicciones que
tenemos contra los posibles presidentes
el posible presidente de este país se
están haciendo notar